the sunray building is an industrial
building the first of its kind in the
furniture international hub in Seneca
Doane one of the great things is that
because you know it has multi topologies
we thought it would be very exciting to
look at the business of sunray and how
we can depict it in the form of the
building and when we went to their
factory it was lots of boxes stacked on
boxes by using this imagery of boxes we
could also physically separate the
different users and yet when they all
come together it has a composition that
works very well Singapore's we all know
is hot and humid and one of the things
that we really treasure is natural
ventilation so this building placed a
lot of emphasis on natural ventilation
so one of the reasons why we use louvers
horizontally and vertically is because
it helps to promote wind flow through
the building one of the unique features
in the design is the color yellow is
yellow because it's a corporate color of
sunray and sunray is yellow rays of Sun
it has varying shades of yellow to
create textures I think we can bring the
design scene of Singapore to the next
level by really just sharing with the
rest of the world what we've done here
the president's design award encourages
design thought which advances critical
thinking in various fields of design it
is a great honor to win the president's
design award my advice to emerging
designers is to always do research do a
lot of critical thinking before diving
deep into an idea through innovation I
feel only comes through understanding
deeply the fundamentals of an issue and
having the ability to forecast potential
problems and challenges